Netflix's Stranger Things has captivated audiences
with a satisfying throwback to classic '80s
paranormal thrillers But how'd this modern
classic actually happen?
Here's a look at the untold truth of Stranger
Things.
Super Duffer Brothers
Twins Matt and Ross Duffer, the writer-director
duo who created the show, showed an early
interest in filmmaking, experimenting with
home movies as early as third grade.
They pursued their passion by studying film
at Chapman University.
Their first movie was Hidden, a horror film
which didn't receive wide release.
But it did catch the eye of M. Night Shyamalan,
who hired them to work on his series Wayward
Pines.
That experience gave the Duffers the start
they needed to pitch their own series.
With the help of producers Dan Cohen and Shawn
Levy, Netflix eventually bought the show—but
only after it was rejected by at least 15
other networks.
Strong Island
Stranger Things takes place in Hawkins, Indiana.
But the Duffers originally wanted to play
with the concept of a waterside setting—specifically
Montauk, New York.
The region's real-life history may have inspired
their story: legend has it that the town's
Camp Hero Air Force Base was a lot like MKUltra
in very disturbing ways, including serving
as the site of rumored government experiments
with mind control on kidnapped children.
Georgia On My Mind
Stranger Things was filmed in the Atlanta,
Georgia area, which is also home to a number
of television and film productions, so there
was just bound to be a location crossover
or two.
The Bellwood Quarry, where fake-Will's body
is found and Mike is bullied into cliff-diving,
was the same site seen in The Walking Dead's
first season and The Hunger Games movies.
Your next Hollywood-inspired trip destination
has just been booked.
Font Of Wisdom
Most of Stranger Things' pop culture references
were put in on purpose, and the title art
font is no exception.
It's an altered version of Benguiat, which
was used on a slew of classic Stephen King
book covers—including but not limited to
Cujo, Salem's Lot, Firestarter, Pet Sematary,
Misery, and The Stand.
The typeface, which was designed by Ed Benguiat,
was also popularized in 1978, and also has
been seen in the openings for films like Star
Trek Generations and Star Trek: First Contact.
'80s cinema school
Finding the right child star for Stranger
Things was important, because even though
there are cast members with higher billing,
the show's heart revolves around the kids.
The Duffers auditioned 906 boys and 307 girls
for the roles using scenes from Stand By Me.
When they finally settled on the cast, they
were sent home with instructions to watch
films like Poltergeist and The Goonies to
get a sense of the look and feel of the show
to come.
Clearly it paid off.
On the first day of filming, they shot the
first Dungeons and Dragons session that starts
the series.
The Duffers told Entertainment Weekly:
"Our boys flew through the scene effortlessly
and energetically, and their chemistry was
electric; they felt like they had known each
other their whole lives.
Other than when we sold the show to Netflix,
this was the single biggest moment for Stranger
Things."
Buzzcut, Baby
Millie Bobby Brown, who turned in stunning
work as the superpowered Eleven, didn't know
she'd have to shear off her locks until she'd
already won the role.
She eventually came around to the idea after
being shown an image of Charlize Theron's
buzzcut in Mad Max: Fury Road.
She was also encouraged by an old pic of co-star
Winona Ryder, who'd sported a pixie cut in
her younger days.
"Sort of a choice-"
"And I showed you my school picture."
"And Winona showed me-so I thought like, ya
know Winona looked cool back in the day with
ya know the pixie cut, and I thought, maybe
I could bring it back?"
Channeling Meryl Streep
Winona Ryder, a legend of the '80s herself
thanks to Heathers and Beetlejuice, was one
of the first casting picks for Stranger Things.
But when she was approached about the show,
she had no idea what streaming was, and little
TV experience.
For her character's look, though, she found
inspiration in Meryl Streep's performance
in Silkwood, which was released the same year
as the show's events.
Her hair in the show was something of a tribute
to the Oscar-winning star.
Stephen King is a fan
As one of the biggest inspirations for Stranger
Things, author Stephen King's praise of the
show is worth a lot.
The author wrote on Twitter that when he watched
the show it was like "watching Steve King's
Greatest Hits … in a good way," and graded
the program an A for "pure fun."
Interestingly enough, Finn Wolfhard, who plays
Mike Wheeler in the show, will star in another
big Stephen King-inspired property: the upcoming
big-screen adaptation of IT, which—full
circle!—the Duffers tried in vain to direct
years ago.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you want to see in Stranger Things, season
two…